So alright,
next borders are reasonable.
How about that?
The law is the border that stops someone
from stealing your
laptop.
If it's an apple laptop,
well it's the sort of laptop that has
social justice warrior would carry and
then the social justice warrior is going
to be very irritated if you happen to
purloin their laptop and then you might
point out to them,
you know it's a border that protects you
from having that thing taken and they
say,
well,
the borders should be open.
It's okay man,
no problem,
and you hand over that laptop right now
and everything else you own too.
If you don't like borders and you can
get rid of the damn walls in your house
and you don't need doors on your bedroom
either and we can keep an eye on you
whenever we want and so much for
borders.
One of the things that really differs
between liberals and conservatives
between the left and the right is the
right is in the right legs,
tight borders between things.
It's part of being conscientious at
every level,
conceptually,
sexually,
familiarly,
provincially,
nationally.
The right says,
look,
let's keep.
Let's keep the borders between things
pretty distinct and the left says,
yeah,
maybe not because some of those borders
are in the wrong place and a little bit
more free flow of information wouldn't
be a bad thing,
and the thing is that right,
but so are the Conservatives and that's
why you have to talk.
It's like,
well,
we've got some borders.
That's a good thing.
Maybe some of them need to be moved
around a little bit and that's what the
political dialogue is for,
but that doesn't mean that borders
themselves are a bad idea.
They're a great idea because without
borders,
everything Nash's into the same
untenable state of undifferentiated
chaos and you can't live in that.
And so the people who are trying to tear
down the borders conceptually,
politically and practically what they
want is the chaos that that would bring
the either want that or they're too
foolish to know that their pursuits will
produce that.
So let's,
let's,
let's be a little bit clear that if you
stand up and say,
yeah,
borders,
they're okay,
they've got their problems,
but they're okay.
That doesn't make you a a,
a bigot beyond redemption.
It just makes you someone with some
sense and it's actually okay to be
someone with some sense limits on
immigration are also reasonable.
Well,
we need to figure out what those limits
are and that's what the bloody political
dialogue is for,
but the fact that it should be limited
to some degree is also reasonable.
Otherwise,
why not just open the borders and let
everybody come in?
Well,
the reason you don't do that is because
a complex system cannot tolerate
extensive transformation over too short
a period of time.
Now you want immigrants to come in,
especially if they're the sorts of
immigrants who are likely to contribute
properly to the success of your polity.
And lots of immigrants do that.
I mean,
I think the vast majority,
for example,
of entrepreneurs in the United States
come from the Indian subcontinent.
So great.
You know,
bring them over.
They're highly educated,
they're extraordinarily productive.
They make lots of new businesses and
then they pump money like back,
like mad back in India.
Good deal.
But that doesn't mean that we have.
Our arms are open to everyone
immigration policy because it's complete
rubbish.
All that means is you're not thinking
about it,
so when he hears a coded to that for
conservatives,
here's something I've been thinking
about this a lot lately.
It should not be assumed that citizens
have societies that have not evolved
functional individual rights predicated
polities will hold values in keeping
with such policies,
so we could say,
look,
there are a lot of countries in the
world that are not governed well.
The vast majority of them,
right,
and they'd be not governed well forever,
and to me that means that there's
something wrong with the values that are
held collectively by the people who've
established those polarities.
Well,
you shouldn't be naive and assume that
merely because you move them to a new
country,
they're going to let their innate
democratic longings,
Florida.
It doesn't work that way.
So if you stand up and say,
look,
you know,
let's be a little cautious.
Let's make sure that we don't transform
our society so rapidly that we lose what
we have.
Let's be careful about that.
That doesn't mean that you're a morally
reprehensible demon.
It just means that you're conservative
and it's a reasonable position to hold,
so there's no sense in apologizing to it
for it.
Now,
that doesn't mean you get to like hide
your bigotry under a mask of moral
virtue.
You know,
the discrimination issue is quite clear
as far as I'm concerned,
so that's associated with bigotry.
If you have two people who are applying
for a job,
you should pick the one that's most
qualified and not pay any attention to
any of the other attributes of the
person that have nothing to do with the
job.
Okay?
Right.
I think basically,
I think we figured that out in about
1965 now.
We're not doing it perfectly,
you know,
but it's not that much later than 1965
and our society particularly in Canada
is pretty damn open.
You can come in here and if you work
hard and if you're fortunate and you
don't get sick and God smiles on you,
so to speak,
you can be successful.
There's still prejudice on reasonable
prejudice and discrimination,
but our society is not as the radical
egalitarian.
Equity promoters have it structurally
racist,
bigoted,
and misogynistic.
No,
not only that,
just so you know,
there is a review.
There was a recent review published and
I mean recent 2017.
Looking at that damn literature on
unconscious bias and I knew the
literature to begin with.
There is no evidence that unconscious
bias can be measured properly,
not reliably.
There also no evidence whatsoever that
if you do measure it and you can't very
that it does any better job of
predicting actual say bias and
prejudice.
Then just tests of attitude.
So the notion that our culture is
somehow structurally misogynistic and
racist and the reason for that is
because of the unconscious bias of the
monsters who are running it is is,
well maybe it's not wrong,
but I can tell you one thing about it.
It is not a scientifically justifiable
proposition and that's what it's being
passed off as.
And I placed that firmly at the feet of
the social psychologists with social
psychology happens to be a fairly
corrupt disciplined by the way,
and the people who invented the Implicit
Association test which measures
unconscious bias because they have not
come out publicly to the degree that
they should have.
Instead,
our test,
which was for experimental purposes,
is being misused politically.
You know your damn judges now because of
federal five feet,
half to undergo mandatory unconscious
bias training before they can sit on the
bench and so you don't think that's
political reeducation is because you're
not paying attention and there is zero
evidence that it does what it's supposed
to.
And I would also recommend to all of you
if you happen to be in a workplace that
introduces diversity training or
unconscious bias training as a mandatory
requirement.
You tell them in no uncertain terms that
you are not participating in a process
that deems you bigoted and misogynistic.
Without evidence of that being the case.
And if you trot off to the training,
then you've just agreed that that's who
you are.
And believe me,
once you've agreed to that man,
you'll be agreeing to a bunch of things
you don't want to agree soon afterwards.
So it's time just to put a stop to that.
None of that.
None of that unconscious bias retreading
especially not the mandatory type.
People should be paid so that they are
able and willing to perform socially
useful and desirable duties.
Okay.
So the radical leftists,
they react to me this way.
They say,
well you hold a position of privilege
and power and I think first you don't
know a god damn thing about being.
You have no idea how I got to my
position of privilege and power and it
was no birthright.
I can tell you that I was a small,
like thick glasses,
intellectual,
non.
What do you call that?
Athletic Child,
you know,
it was a year younger than my peers.
I suffered plenty of.
What would you say?
Trouble for my loud mouth and my
intellect when I was growing up.
You know,
I had my struggles.
I'm not complaining about it.
The point is is that you can't attribute
privileged to a class of people.
You know when you can't attribute power
to people who opt in to occupy a
position of competence and authority,
either there's some possibility that
they occupied that because they worked
hard and were fortunate.
Let's not forget about that and had some
good social support and didn't have some
horrible disease.
Thank God,
but you can't just make the case that
the position is there as a reward.
It's not there as far as a reward at
all.
It's there as a consequence of the
person offering something valuable to
those who want to pay for it and the
reason you pay for them isn't to reward
them.
It isn't so that you give them a pat on
the back and say,
well,
you're a good person and you know you
deserve this position.
It's because you're saying to them,
produce.
We find what you're producing a value
and so we're going to give you what you
need in order to be motivated to keep
doing it,
but it's not because we like you and
it's not because we.
We respect your rights.
It has nothing to do with equity.
It's we're trying to get every God damn
thing we can from you as fast as
possible and we're going to pay you to
do it and so people deserve their damn
pay and the reason they deserve it isn't
because it's a reward.
It's because that's how you get
productive people to do things that are
difficult and time consuming and that
perhaps they wouldn't do on their own
accord to continue doing them so you can
benefit from it.
So the whole notion that,
you know,
we're awarding positions of privilege
too,
oppressive patriarchal types.
It's like we just have to get rid of
that.
Enough of that.
That's nonsense.
It's absolute nonsense.
And the other thing too is,
you know,
it's only been 30,
40 years,
50 years since women had reliable birth
control,
right?
And we're able to enter the workforce on
Moss.
I'll tell you man,
we've produced a cultural revolution in
like 50 years.
Women are everywhere.
It's like how bloody fast you expect
something like that to go.
And what makes you think that pushing it
really hard,
he's going to make it go any better.
I mean,
as far as I can tell,
we manage that transition about as well
as we possibly could have.
We're still sorting out the details,
but the fact that you know this is
coming very rapidly down the pipes,
the fact that half of our corporate
board members are women is not
indicative of the fact that we live in
an unconsciously biased,
misogynistic,
patriarchal society.
Sorry,
wrong not correct and so we shouldn't be
allowing and this is happening very,
very rapidly.
You can be sure Kathleen Wynne is going
to be putting this in his policies
rapidly as she possibly can.
These equity demands to ensure that
there is proportional representation of
every gender,
every sex,
every race,
every ethnicity,
at every level of every organization.
It's like,
really?
We're going to do that by governmental
Fiat.
It's like,
that's not a society I want to live in.
I tell you and I can.
I can I quite certain that if you lived
in that society for any length of time,
you'd learned very rapidly that it isn't
a society that you'd want to be part of
either.